what is happening there reject nation
thank you so much for clicking on this
video today we are gonna be covering
arcane episode six but hey before we do
that thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video guys skillshare is
like a pandora's box of knowledge they
have literally thousands of classes
across a plethora of subjects perfect
for helping you expand your existing
passions and pick up new skills this
month i checked out thomas frank's
productivity for creatives course
because i am neither productive nor very
creative you can say that again i am
neither productive nor creative believe
it thomas's class spans the ins and outs
of the professional mindset and the art
to building your inspiration like a
muscle i wish i had muscles yeah i'm an
inspiration and so inspired right now he
also walks you through organizing your
physical and digital workspaces as well
as the collaborative process and how to
delegate tasks john since they're not
creative why don't you tell them how
they can get access to i will greg thank
you for delegating that task to me the
first 1000 people to use our link in the
description box will receive a free
trial membership to skillshare's premium
service and after that it's not ten
thousand dollars a month it's ten
dollars a month with not three
commercials not two no commercials
like like this one
so what are you waiting for people sign
up today and start building those skills
get creative
wish i could
that that's young victor yeah
he's been an inventor all his life
cool
don't be afraid
you built this
loneliness is often the byproduct of a
gifted mind
i like that hmm
she's dying
i'm attempting to prevent that can i
help you want to assist me
we can be loners together oh he's always
been so passionate about helping you
should be proud of what you've
accomplished victor my contributions
will be short-lived
even in your memory oh buddy it's a sad
truth that those who shine brightest
often burn
fastest some deep ass conversations
they're having
i didn't know you were an artist
there's quite a lot about me you don't
know that's why i don't trust you yeah
victor saved my life once now he needs
me and there's nothing i can do why did
you come to me with this nothing feels
impossible when i'm with you huh do i
trust her
[Laughter]
that's the big question
come on man crack it
[Applause]
[Music]
is it working
be careful
[Laughter]
we lost her
lost hoop
she's a badass yeah and then some
that woman is just suffering so much you
know
no amount of power-ups can give her the
edge
i feel like you and i got off on the
wrong arm
[Laughter]
no need it's your sister
her back in town it's only a matter of
time before you implode and silco
finally gets the message that you're
about as good for our cause as you were
for your family
oh god time daddy joined us
you were so busy little ren here saw me
in that's such a sinister cliche yeah
oh it gets worse
vander's daughter
she was about your age
her father went on a long trip and daddy
here assured me that she left with him
ah
she's a curator
just like them she does whatever she
wants i
can't control her
uh
dead of what use are you
say smarter things cop
they cannot be allowed to resurface
do we understand each other
[Music]
[Music]
breathes life
cool
hop in it yeah we've ever seen jess it
it could be the key to augmenting
physiology extending life making me not
die
oh this is one minor hiccup there it's
happened to everyone
i can't determine why
they're rejecting the transmutation you
got to stay in the magic world or
something
maybe the exchange isn't equivalent
maybe you need to give more
time to mess some people uh
come on caitlyn what is this place these
are the kind of people you topsiders
don't want to think about wind up
cave full of gulliver oh my god it's
like lepers oh yeah
i shouldn't have left you
it's all right
despite us all uh
i can tell
you have a good heart
you've got a good heart
he sees is terror if ever you've put
faith in my guidance hear me now
i've seen nations destroyed by a single
seed and it looked
exactly like this
you've changed what did you do
what do you mean i don't know what
you're talking about
this is a violation of the ethos
i will have it destroyed one way or
another
that's your opinion we'll see if the
council agrees
oh [ __ ] jace is on the council now yeah
throwing a weight around
but i i i i'm a friend
or at least it was i mean i i ordered
old man my life oh is it that guy
she makes
potions helps people here with
with
this
oh
why would you take something that does
that to you
i just wanted to feel what it was like
to be somebody
to make other people afraid oh die out
guy
anyway i i don't want her to see me
like this tell her i'm sorry
about everything
okay
dude
okay hey lyn
[Laughter]
tax at the hex case and in the academy
square enforcers fear to set foot in the
lanes all under your watch oh dude let's
slow down jake i've been on the council
for like three days my dude
we need a leadership focused on the
future not the past
you are the true father of beltover and
your years of service can never be
repaid i believe it's time we gave the
beloved founder of our city
a well-deserved retirement oh wow jace
[Music]
[Laughter]
with my deepest respect and appreciation
professor
oh no
boy
no ho ho ho no
[Music]
oh wow
chase barely spoke
all you guys are voting
back on your feet
i'm sick of guessing who's gay or not in
the show all right everyone's a little
gay
people keep telling me i'm right
you used to live here
who's powder
why did you say that
oh you sick sadistic bastard
you don't know your limits girl it's
what god vander killed what drove your
sister away and it's why i'm here right
now
yeah well
oh no you talk too much
we're all crumbling down
wherever you are light it up and i'll
find you
[Music]
oh
guys
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] is so goddamn baby
go
go to her
oh rio will live
you did this
i thought you understood
the mutation must survive
so
victor aided in the creation of shimmer
i guess he at least
this guy just survives every burning
building yes
is going to be one giant scar by the end
of the show
oh
[Music]
oh
go find the beacon
powder
pie
oh powder
[Music]
dude
i tried to come back i promise i did but
i i got arrested
marcus i don't know i it doesn't matter
i just
i never thought i'd see you again
oh
what matters is we're together
oh no oh no no
no no no golly oh golly
who are you
it's okay she's a friend sarika wasn't
lying you're with an enforcer listen
we can work this out this is a trick
you're playing me oh shut up
i'm in no movie oh
god
you're a class act sister
sister thought i missed her but you
wouldn't miss her
powder
oh my god
you can fire that thing if you want but
i'm not going anywhere
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
wow
jesus
damn she's good
absolutely
like a bird
[Music]
oh wow that's actually
oh no
you gotta wait now
the weight factory
ah jesus
what a good [ __ ] show
one hell of an episode i thought this
was such a richly they're all pretty
nuanced and very
very rich but i thought they had some
really strong debates here this time
around a lot of really great like
philosophical existential
ponderings especially amongst the people
of
oh [ __ ] me piltover
there we go
which is something i wanted a little bit
more of that's something i was kind of
craving so actually watching them at
odds creates more of a of a fantastic
dramatic tension you start to see where
this is all sort of being built towards
and like especially that boating session
uh when it comes to heimdinger sky the
way how she is behaving i interrupt this
review to tell you that for some reason
i kept calling mel skye acting like
she's a little bit reluctant towards
this i'm like i feel like this is what
you always wanted
it seems like what you always want you
want that progressive disregard for the
current safety move yeah i was a little
surprised by how quick they voted the
points brought up are not bad points
that's what i thought was great about
that's what makes a solid debate when
you hear both arguments and you're like
you're both right in a lot of ways
actually and i could see why you all
went one way it was just a bummer
because you know a heimdinger's
intentions are all good especially when
you cut to seeing what he foresees the
terrible you know monstrous outcomes
that could come from this this almost it
feels almost inevitable for him of where
this hex tech could possibly lead to
he's always
been forewarned about it and now just
the progression of this he's not going
to be able to have any oversight of how
it goes down and it's like he he like
raced this guy he raised this jason that
he just sort of he turns on him in the
end you know it's heartbreaking yeah it
hurts a lot and it's funny to me that i
mean i do think it's interesting that
they didn't have like much of any debate
between the other council members
although i think it is kind of motivated
too by the idea that they establish
heimerdinger is just a scientist he
doesn't have like a political background
that brought him to the council you know
it's like he is simply a person who is
concerned for yeah like the safe
advancement of things and so thus he
almost seems like the most good-hearted
on the council like i can see how
everybody else being drawn is these so
politically minded characters and these
characters who have you know these
financial interests in which you know
the advancement of hex tech figures
heavily i can ultimately see how the
corruption won out pretty quickly but it
is heartbreaking because yeah i mean
heimerdinger's got a lot of solid points
and it's that thing too when you when
you call upon people to trust you
without that explanation i don't know
jace is in an interesting position
because he has been he's he's arisen the
ranks so rapidly in a lot of ways first
with just being accepted for his
experiments and now he's on the council
and it's like it feels like it's only
been a couple days since that happened
and now he's already like riled
everybody up and stuff and so yeah it
seems like everything has gone to his
head in a way that isn't like cliche or
or you know uh petty but is pretty
heartbreaking i mean the way you
motivate people when you're in some type
of like title position or leadership
position is through emotion not so much
through logic like this like how you
move people through with a vision
whereas heimdinger
he has the emotion but jace is currently
exceptionally passionate about where he
stands it's much easier for him to
connect like he he made a really solid
point because it's easy to listen to
heimdinger and go hey hey like we we
should slow this down we don't fully
understand how this technology works but
he lives forever or something right he's
been around for like hundreds of years
at this point
he can have the patience whereas humans
are not afforded such a luxury when jace
made that point about progress and how
why it needs to be sped up
because of the lifespan of a human being
i was like damn that's a really that's a
hard thing to argue with right there
yeah you know especially when you're in
a council full of humans especially this
could help perpetuate human life if you
make the right advancements too you know
yeah a hundred percent watching how that
how that how it went down in a more uh
heartbreaking ominous fashion was made
the build up to it much more rewarding
because i always feel there's something
percolating i'm like where's the really
dark side gonna come through with this
council i don't really trust the sky
character yep let's see what went wrong
here skye is the other girl featured in
the flashback for victor and we did see
that character the scientist lady who's
like compassion or perhaps kind of into
victor right right that
re-contextualizes the whole context for
me but yeah i still call mel skye
throughout this whole thing i mean where
it really seems to be co i'm going to
see how that coalesces with that with
the hextech side of it
with what's going on in the under city
because right now what's really
connecting the dots here is the
storyline of hunting down you know like
the corruption within and then what's
going on with silco and then how that
what's that one guy's name the asian cop
oh goodness i couldn't tell you bring
prick up uh
cop who's a dick but also down on his
luck and he's you just feel
kind of bad but also like oh you you
made your bed
yeah i don't feel bad feel bad for his
don't feel bad for him at all he's doing
the investigative stuff so that's what's
really connecting the dots there in the
underworld and i really love what they
handled
like that
i'm always just insanely like this has a
tight lock on me whenever we're in the
under city and whenever we're either
with violet or silco or jinx either one
of those characters i'm just immediately
just like glued to everything that's
happening before me i'm liking the
relationship that's really forming
between caitlyn and violet because it
seems to be this episode in particular
seemed to constantly have the
conversation of the gray area right down
to when you know violet
express expresses how much scorn she has
for people of the under cities but i
mean uh piltover especially the
enforcers yet you have caitlyn here who
is showing her more aid than ever anyone
before her you know going through this
mission taking care of her helping her
out physically even trying to be there
for her emotionally as well there seems
to be all right i keep saying [ __ ] that
keeps getting me in trouble in the
comments but there seems to be
all right there's a look there that
could just be compassionate friends and
then somebody looked like they could be
maybe sexually attracted to each other
whatever or maybe the characters are
just open to that sure and it comes out
in the body language a little bit like
maybe there's not a huge thing that will
be maybe they were not going to get
together but i don't know i feel like
it's fair to read they they
intentionally put nuances into the body
language yeah they just had a really uh
drawn out look towards each other when
they're really closely close and the way
you frame that profile of them you see
explore the grays of that and then of
course going further into the under city
watching how where they used to hide out
their home has just turned into utter
ruins and it's become this like
uh like cave man
leprosy drug addict lifestyle for all
these people and you really see because
i was actually i think i brought that up
in the in the last review of like i want
to kind of see what the effects are with
the the sheen that's what they call it
shimmer shimmer machine the shimmer the
same same idea uh with the sh with the
shimmer i wanted to see like how has the
shimmer affected you know the the under
city and then here you get a great
visual of it where it feels uh really
like a horror movie very haunting and
you watch these these good souls who
have just become addicted to
to this like that was so uncomfortable
when they show silko and he's just like
dangling it like like they're animals in
front of him
and they're so submissive oh yeah i mean
he really is highlighted in that moment
as this like slum lord who is like yeah
who's able to exploit the most desperate
people right he's the he is like the
king of a ruin and it's especially clear
in that moment yeah it's heartbreaking
and sinister all at the same time and i
love the ultimate gray of the
confrontation that comes i mean i'm
curious to see what'll happen with
violet and powder going forward because
it seems like powders definitely jinx
severed her tie with silko at least you
know
threw down the gauntlet and i love their
reunion because there's so many you were
talking about like the grays and having
this enforcer here who's shown violet
way more you know compassion and
assistance than pretty much anybody else
lately that whole reunion was so fraught
and so tense and so
heart-wrenching too because yeah it's
like there's this chaos moment of like
no no she's with me and i know we all
have our biases against each other but
in this moment we can't afford to like
succumb to all that stuff and i got
really caught up in all that it seems
like everything is slowly pulling apart
and i think the way that they utilize
all the different
concerns is interesting because it part
way through i had to catch myself and go
for as far off the handle as jace
arguably flies in this episode it's like
he is responsible for breaking violet
out and like having her you know on to
the next part of the story that she's on
right now and so they're great at
drawing these character conflicts and
then making you wonder where everyone's
gonna end up because everyone's got
really palpable trauma and trauma's
messy and you know misunderstandings can
really exacerbate things well they had
great visual storytelling just within
that fight sequence alone like how
violet is having difficulty coming to
terms with who jinx has turned into and
of course like the constant confusion
and inner conflict that seems to be the
uh like at 100 miles per hour all the
time with jinx
at any given moment like so easily
triggered you know i love how
are you real
violet like i love that as as a choice
for when she first sees her that's such
a big part of her character now she
can't turn discern the difference in
reality and what's just a figment of her
own imagination and then you see her
even in that scene answering to parts
that are just living in her own
psychosis but even when she's violet is
watching jinx just go crazy on the where
fire lighters or the fire lights the
fire lights going crazy on the fire
lights watching just how
you know maniacally gleeful and violent
jinx has evolved into and violet is just
trying to you know wrap her head around
like oh my god this is what my sister
has become you know like the last time
she saw her sister she was just this
insanely timid introverted fearful
character and then now she is just
something else she's eating 100 the
opposite of all that you know having to
deal with the shock of such a situation
and we still don't really understand the
depth of how much the seeds of the fire
lights it looks like the next act is
when we'll be unpacking that and then of
course with victor everything with the
backstory there with his first mentor
yeah that he had seeing what the
mutation like the the the the acts of
what he did to heal the creature he
thought were repulsive and not like they
were not morally right and then now
after every his experiences of being on
the council and then while trying to
heal himself and understand that the
power of the magic because it seemed
like that cave had a bunch of magic [ __ ]
yeah at least those magical blooms and
things yeah so being involved with that
now looks like he's going to be taking
on some self-experiments as well you
gotta mutate
yeah so there's a mutate it's slowly
escalating into one giant collapse yeah
it's everything vander and it's like you
have the characters of vander and
heimdinger and you're watching
as their greatest fears are coming true
slowly but surely at the hands of all
their proteges yeah yeah for sure
because no one would listen to their
warning signs it's great writing
absolutely and the visuals are cool as
always
always always so cool all right guys
well that is it for um
hurricane episode six keep a lookout for
reaction to the next episode
[Music]